so you have an environment where
political stress is at
all time highs you have 62 percent of
americans also an all-time high calling
for a third party you have people who
are touching the political system like
you and sagar and other you know dozens
of other people we know who are throwing
their hands up privately or publicly
saying wow like this really is a
dysfunctional mess you know that like
this thing's not gonna somehow
uh write itself
and then
you still have this sense but it can't
change
uh and in my mind there is a question as
to how things go in our country things
are not going well
and so if you say look we're going to
ride this duopoly we're going to write
it to ruin and i think a lot of people
sense that and agree with that
and then when someone raises their hand
and says maybe we should change it then
[Laughter]
by the way
tens of millions of americans agree with
that
then everyone's like oh no no like can't
change it i mean arguing for the status
quo at a certain point is a real losing
argument particularly at a time when
millions of americans are looking around
for some kind of change alternative
restructuring it's happening in every
other
industry
except for politics because we're being
told that it can't change
[Music]
[Music]
this week's episode on forward i sit
down with sagar and jetty and marshall
kosloff on the realignment and talk
about how we fix our gridlock in
washington it's a great conversation
hope you enjoyed
andrew yang welcome to the realignment
sauger it's great to be here thanks for
having me
good to see you man i'm really glad you
could do uh you could do this you know
it's interesting marshall and i got the
book the advanced copy there obviously
was a lot of consternation around the
announcement but having you know known
you and covered you now for a long time
i think what i wanted to start out was
this
what experience from the democratic
party
in the primary for the president and the
2020 race and in the new york mayoral
race what experiences what reflections
did you have that led you to conclude we
need a new third party and write this
book like describe to us how you got to
where you are in that process
i'd be happy to and
uh grateful to to you for
being one of the media figures who
covered the me and the presidential
uh
when you know we were being ignored
by a lot of other people
um
so i came off the trail in february of
2020 and i set to writing
in part because i wanted to document
experiences that i had had zero time to
reflect on because you imagine running
for president
in the
heart of the campaign
it's just go go go all the time
and so it was while i was writing this
book last year
that i came to grips with what i thought
was wrong which is that we we have a
system of incentives that make it so
that even very noble well-intended
people will get there
and not really
either be able to deliver uh or over
time have any vision they they they
might have had watered down
[Laughter]
so
uh and i didn't come up with this all on
my own i mean as you've read the book
you know that i've been influenced by
jonathan height and ezra klein and
catherine gail and lawrence lessig and
michael porter and these other thinkers
but i i came to realize that
the system
itself is the problem and that there was
no real way
that even a great person
from either party who got in there was
somehow going to make fundamental
changes
and then when you arrive at that
conclusion then you think okay well how
could you make real changes and i
believe the biggest
mechanism we have to change is the
closed party primaries that if we change
to open
primaries and ranked choice voting that
you'd have very very different
incentives and different points of view
so
i arrived at this conclusion and one of
the things i feel like i owe people is
to say what i really think the answer is
and then i don't have it in me to say
hey someone should do this
and then just go on with my life i mean
that that's not how i'm wired
i don't see myself as a writer or
thinker so much as a builder operator
doer
and so if i say look here's the problem
here's the solution
then i'd better bust my ass trying to
provide the solution and that's how the
forward party uh was originated
it's funny i want to tell a quick media
story that has the two of us
tangentially connected because it speaks
to the media
space when you first enter the race
which i actually really appreciate that
chapter in the book so i was a
researcher at a new show called firing
line on pbs so this is in er this is in
may june 2018
and when our producer says hey like we
met this this guy
at a
birthday party he had this book about
ubi should we book this person and the
answer was obviously no because we
didn't know who you were so there's just
this really funny intersection of sauger
was in the you know non-mainstream media
space i was in the mainstream media pbs
space and there was just something that
was missing out of undercurrent there
which i just have always wanted to just
mention to you i thought was funny
obviously if we booked you it wasn't
very good for the show itself and that
was a huge mess on our end but i want to
go to something you just said which is
really identifying the dysfunction
and the real hopelessness of the people
feeling the political system right now
because i think
look i'll just be open i'm skeptical of
third parties but what i've noticed
from a lot of commentators in the
mainstream who've poopooed the idea is
they have not understood
the way people actually feel about this
topic as in people genuinely feel as if
the system is corrupt and doesn't
function however to give you some
historical context you know we've been
through periods like this before
post-civil war
industrial era when we're trying to
reckon of all these big changes
it's been easy to say that things
couldn't change but eventually they did
without these big structural changes
what makes right now in this moment
unique and different from those prior
periods where we could have a lot of the
same feelings
marshall i think if you do rewind the
tape uh you would find that we're
actually in the midst of an accidental
duopoly i mean like
in the sense that the founding fathers
didn't come together and say you know
what we need two parties
that will be
warring with each other uh and
at some point turning us into a
polarized nation on the brink of
political violence and civil war i mean
that that's no one's plan
um and so what
the way you frame that question is is
that
there have been these other episodes in
history where people have thought we
needed something different and then the
duopoly has uh continued but if you
rewind further
you have founders who are very very
anti-factionalism and
anti-bipartisan and if they saw this
duopoly they would be shocked and
horrified and think this is literally
the worst design
that anyone
could come up with so you have an
environment where political stress is at
all time highs you have 62 percent of
americans also an all-time high calling
for a third party you have people who
are touching the political system like
you and sagar and other you know dozens
of other people we know who are throwing
their hands up privately or publicly
saying wow like this really is a
dysfunctional mess you know that like
this thing is not gonna somehow
uh write itself
and then
you still have this sense but it can't
change
uh and in my mind there is a question as
to how things go in our country things
are not going well and so if you say
look we're gonna ride this duopoly we're
gonna write it to ruin and i think a lot
of people sense that and agree with that
and then when someone raises their hand
and says maybe we should change it then
[Laughter]
by the way
tens of millions of americans agree with
that
then everyone's like oh no no like can't
change it i mean arguing for the status
quo at a certain point is a real losing
argument particularly at a time when
millions of americans are looking around
for some kind of change alternative
restructuring it's happening in every
other
industry
except for politics because we're being
told that it can't change
[Music]
let's talk about the mechanic though
like ranked choice voting um i wouldn't
say you know new york it was kind of a
let's say didn't go so well at least in
terms of how it appeared that being said
the new york board of elections has
always been kind of a hot mess what are
your reflections on the actual
implementation of ranked choice voting
that you yourself had to participate in
and what are the promises from within
the book that led you to really believe
that this this thing alone could fix so
many of our problems why
well first you have to differentiate
between the ability of the new york boe
to execute
um
and the process itself
95 percent of new yorkers found ranked
choice voting easy to use 77 want to do
it again and if you can get four out of
five new yorkers to agree on something
i'd say that's pretty damn good
and you also have to differentiate
between ranked choice voting within a
party primary which was the case in new
york city and ranked choice voting in an
open primary which is
in my mind a much more dramatic
improvement
so even in the mayoral race
uh people were saying oh turnout went up
from you know let's call it eight
hundred thousand nine hundred thousand
votes uh which still means only about
eleven percent of new yorkers voted in
that primary and
the next mayor might get five percent or
something along along those lines so
these are not numbers that you should be
pumped about
but but that's a function of the closed
party primary system more than ranked
choice voting so rank choice voting does
something really really powerful and i'm
just going to reference
some of the objections that people have
uh leveled at any whisper of andrew yang
starting a third party it's like oh
you're going to ruin it for x
and uh and
part of that is like well sure if you
have this archaic plurality voting
system um you get to bludgeon anyone who
comes up because they're going to ruin
it for someone
theoretically even though that makes a
bunch of leaps and assumptions that
probably aren't true in the rest of it
but if you make a change to ranked
choice voting then all of a sudden
there's no spoiler effect you can vote
for
the minor third party candidate first
and then let's say hypothetically the
democrats second and then no one can
accuse you of ruining anything
um you have different coalitions that
come together you have to appeal to a
majority
uh it doesn't reward the extremes like
our current system does and right now
the biggest problem and i want folks who
are listening to this uh to understand
why things seem so broken in our system
congress has a national approval rating
of 28
the re-election rate for individual
members is 92 percent think about that
system for a second and the reason why
those numbers are so different is that
the average legislator does not have to
appeal to 51 percent of people in their
district to get reelected they just have
to appeal to the most partisan
12 to 17 percent really
and so if you think that legislators
don't seem very reasonable or common
sense it's because their incentives are
not to be very reasonable or common
sense so if you were to change that to
rank choice voting open primary all of a
sudden it's like oh wait i can't just uh
you know frankly placate the 20 most
extreme people in my district i actually
have to appeal to 51 percent of you you
would see everyone's behavior change
you'd see arguments change and rank
choice voting theoretically would make
negative campaigning
uh
less popular because if you trash
someone then they look bad you look bad
and then the third person who's not
trashing anyone looks better by
comparison
you know we've had catherine gale on the
show before so really suggest that
listeners take a look at that episode
from last june to get really deep into
the ideas we're talking about here i'm
curious when it comes to the open
primary debate
what lessons do you take from
california's experience because
typically you know california is a state
that is experimented with making these
changes for over almost 10 years now and
it's hard to say that california
reflects the dynamics you're talking
about so the state is still hyper
polarized between urban and rural
there's still a very specific political
class of folks who have tend to keep on
the up and up no matter what the
republican party has not become any more
competitive than it was before actually
if anything it's become less competitive
what are the lessons from the california
experience that as you're looking to
make that model more national reformers
like you should take into account
the biggest
deficit in my view of the california
change is that it's top two uh where
i think that katherine gayle's on the
right track that if you had top five
ranked choice voting then you'd have
much more diverse points of view in
every district uh right now it's an
improvement because it's open primary
and anyone can run but in real life what
that generally means is that like the
the
like the top two candidates will be the
democrat the republican in most
instances maybe every once in a while a
democrat versus a democrat
um and you're not really giving rise to
a whole lot of dynamism uh that said
californians satisfaction with the state
legislature did go up in the wake of
this and there was an increased level of
competitiveness
and activity on the part of some
legislators who actually felt like they
had to attend to their constituents and
uh maybe campaign a bit more
so uh so there have been some good
things with the change but in my mind uh
the top two uh doesn't do it justice uh
you would want to have more candidates
make it to the general
it you know andrew one of the things i
hear most skeptical i would say my
friends who are much more like maggot
right than me
they have a pretty articulate defense of
the
of the polarized primary system because
they're like no actually some questions
are irreconcilable it's actually a good
thing i'm in order to hold our
legislators to a very very high standard
of what you know our base of our party
wants and make it so that they fight for
that whenever they come to washington
and make it so that you know eventually
this subscribes more to the theory that
you have to have a knockout punch on
certain issues things like guns abortion
which generally are like literally
two-sided what would a rank-choice
voting system fix about that so first of
all tell us why that system is bad um
you know what is the defense of the more
centrist or at least solutions
compromise based strategy in the face of
some genuinely irreconcilable questions
but b
what would the world look like
differently in terms of hashing out a
solution in a in a congressional setting
i think that that argument speaks for
itself in some ways which is look uh if
you want a
strident minority of people to have
outsized influence
um then our current system probably
serves you pretty well
[Laughter]
and that's not just on the right uh you
know there are special interests that
have a real chokehold on democratic
party primaries that have outsized
influence i'm going to call out teachers
unions as one example
and so our policy reflects that
if if
like most americans you think that there
uh is a desire to try and forge middle
ground on some of these problems i mean
when i talked to gun owners as an
example when i was running for president
i thought there was common ground to be
had uh you know the most common
cause of of gun deaths is suicide where
or not the version of gun deaths i
should say um and and so you have that
these problems that affect everybody
um and there are things that i think you
can agree on that would make people safe
for a while in that case
safeguarding constitutional rights so
you wouldn't see in my mind
as binary and approach
and i think that's what a lot of
americans are looking for right now is
to try and find the grounds for
agreement
there is a
really important tension
to what you're describing
in a good way because this is ambitious
and anything ambitious that's not just
tinkering
is going to have tensions
you're talking about
agreement
consensus middle but at the start of the
episode you spoke about
fundamental
changes and i could easily imagine
the conversation you just had about gun
control is impacting
both ends demanding fundamental change
to be kind of ticked off so if i'm
thinking you're center left to left
person you'd say actually andrew
good on the suicide stuff we should work
on that obviously but at a fundamental
level i think that america has too many
guns we should look more like australia
we should look more like europe and
everything that doesn't reflect that is
just tinkering on the edges and then if
you're on the right you would basically
say that all that is you know
uh you know
paving the way to hell with good
intentions which is that ultimately
speaking the center left to left just
wants to remove guns so we're just not
going to negotiate there so how do you
just navigate the fact that on the one
hand you want fundamental changes
but it's hard to see consensus based
policy and politics as building
fundamental changes given what the
audience is actually saying about that
oh i want fundamental changes to a
broken system
you know i'm not saying i want to make
changes uh necessarily in in each of
these issues
i think
this to me is what's necessary in
american life where if you talk to a
group of people
uh on
either side
uh you know that that
most of us want there to be some
progress on some of these issues or
compromise but right now the incentives
make it so that you can become more
politically prominent and raise more
money and sometimes get more votes if
you just articulate points of view on
the extreme and by the way that is
leading us to civil war 2.0 i mean it is
you know like if you look at it it's not
just that peter church's political
stress index is at civil war levels or
that you're seeing violence in the
streets manifest in different ways or
that our political conversations
becoming more and more adversarial where
42 of democrats and republicans think
the other side is evil uh and it's
ruining families and holidays and
everything else like
we're we're trapped in a
uh
dynamic that we need to get out of uh
and
right now the political incentives drive
us to the extremes the media incentives
drive us the extremes the social media
incentives drive
to the extremes where does this go where
does this end one of the
things i've been saying is i want to be
america's wet blanket i want to just
take a wet blanket and be like
like everyone it's going to be all right
we're still
human beings and americans
uh let's let's get a system that breaks
us out of this doom loop uh and then
we'll be able to to come together
and at least have a process that people
feel like they're represented in even if
they're not represented by one of the
two extremes right now
[Music]
now more than ever we could all use
someone to talk to someone who gives us
a bit of a pick-me-up and a lot of
people don't really have that in their
lives honestly i mean i don't know who
the heck i would call but you know what
i would do is i would go to better help
and actually get a licensed therapist
who essentially becomes my on-call
uber
for mental health resource they're
awesome they know what they're doing
they'll actually
be there for you really whenever you
want it really is like magic i genuinely
love
better health sponsoring the podcast
because i know they're actually going to
help people there are folks who are very
close to me who are using better help
and you should too
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang over 1 million people have already
taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
[Music]
so i'm curious you know from a third
party perspective i'm sure you're gonna
get this answer in a million a question
in a million different iterations but it
is important which is
why is a third party the answer i have a
poster on the breaking point set of
william jennings brian somebody i deeply
respect who essentially was a third
party candidate but who transformed and
took over the democratic party in the
1890s um donald trump in many ways the
most transformative political figure of
my lifetime had no connection with the
institutional gop but effectively took
it over from the outside and remade it
in his own image why not andrew you are
famous you've run in the presidential
primary you had the proven ability to
raise tens of millions of dollars in the
democratic party more so than many
establishment figures why not leverage
your part of that democratic party and
try and take it over from within why is
this the answer you have to go with
sagar i think that your importance in
the media landscape can't be understated
you too marshall crystal uh when when
you say like hey there's a sizeable
audience for this
um i think there is a massive audience
and it heartens me that that audience
continues to grow
because a lot of folks say to me in
normal life be like hey i don't even
know where to go for news anymore um and
and some you know and some of them have
found you
and
other independent voices
and i think that's so necessary i think
if we can continue to grow that point of
view then it can become more of a
political force
um
now i i think that you've actually
articulated in some ways a dynamic that
would strengthen the need to have more
political dynamism and multiple parties
so donald trump has taken over the
republican party
i know when you know that there are many
people who have different points of view
than donald trump within the party but
don't breathe a word because if they do
they will be cast out and
their political careers will be ended um
and why is that it's because we have
this two-party system and uh you know
party primaries control so much and that
if you say a bad word about trump uh
you're out i'm gonna suggest that's not
excellent for
democracy generally um and then you have
the democratic party and you say hey
andrew why don't you take over the
democratic party trump style so right
now the big difference between democrats
and republicans is that democrats are
institutionalists and republicans are
not i cannot tell you how many
independents and republicans came up to
me and be like hey man i love you like
you know like way to like go against uh
you know the entrenched machine and the
rest of it
but within the democratic party
they really believe in bureaucracies and
machines and processes to a much much
higher degree and here's a stat that i
think
illustrates the difference between the
parties
69 percent of democrats say they have a
high trust in media by media you know
generally the corporate media right
independence 36
republicans 15
so republicans don't believe it all and
just they think that oh like the you
know the institutions are are uh corrupt
now to get us the democrats are the
people who believe in it and are just
like oh yeah like you know that things
are going all right like just let the
you know people who've been doing it for
a while keep doing it um so you have
very very different dynamics uh and it's
going to influence who winds up emerging
from uh each side
something
i'm wondering is
what do independents
actually believe because i love the 62
percent
gallup poll looking for a third party
we'll put it up in the show notes but if
you actually look into the data it gets
a little interesting given the fact that
for example a decent number of those
independents are
former republicans who actually want the
republican party to become more trumpy
not less
another interesting thing that came to
mind when you're talking about how you
get drummed out of the republican party
if you don't vote for trump is the fact
that
liz cheney
actually voted with trump more if an
elite stefanik did
so there's a certain weird mix of
personalities and coalitions and
dynamics but i guess what i kind of
wonder is if we're actually looking at
the country and the results of the
politics that we're engaging in
considering the fact that liz cheney
actually does once again
vote pretty conservative
aside from the trump thing how is giving
her her own tiny coalition party they
would end up still working with the
republican party on most questions once
again she votes with trump most of the
time far more of inter-competitively
stephonic how would that change things
especially when we're talking about the
big big issues here so for example the
supreme court let's say you have a
progressive party and a center-left
democratic party they're gonna fight
about climate change they're going to
fight with the green new deal they're
going to fight about the 3.5 trillion
dollar budget package but they are going
to vote in lockstep on supreme court
nominees and that is a type of vote
which seems to be drawing or causing the
civil war level conflict we're afraid of
here so how do you just reflect on all
that
i think that if you had uh let's call
them moderate republicans or something
like that
that that was like a non-trump
alternative
i think they might vote along with trump
over and over again on a lot of things
but they might diverge from him on
things like
uh vote counts or like
constitutional protections of elections
or or things like that um i'm going to
suggest that's a very crucial
distinction
that if you had uh
republicans that were ready to do that
then i think we would be in better shape
and
that's a positive
uh that's one of the reasons why i think
we need to build a more resilient system
again and
you if you build a system like this and
it's
now much more susceptible to
authoritarianism and democratic impulses
than most people would imagine
and
we can change that we can fix it we
don't have unlimited time in my opinion
but we should really work on it
do it as quickly as possible
um but it's not about every vote it's
about certain principles that might be
extraordinarily
valuable to to our country and our
democracy
andrew one thing i want you to reflect
on is policy you know when you ran you
were the policy candidate you had the
math hats i used to really believe
in policy that people would vote on
policy but as the elections went on as i
saw trump win 10 million more votes as i
start to see you know stuff turn on
questions of do you think the election
was stolen or not as opposed to did
trump do anything to actually better
your life
i honestly got pretty uh i was pretty
black-pilled on the whole thing and i
guess my question to you is
does policy matter at all
whenever it comes to these because as
you point to and as marshall just
alluded to 62 say that they want a third
party really what that is is they're
holding a middle finger up and saying i
hate the system and i've always
described trump's success
to nothing that he's ever actually done
in office and just directionally being
the voice that agrees with the majority
of the public who say i hate our
institutions and it was really upsetting
to me
to learn that that was enough for
millions of people to cast their vote
for president of the united states uh
how have you reflected on that from when
you announced your polity or run on
policy and are almost in an age where
it's not the defining you know uh it's
not the defining issue of our time
saga i go into this in my book in some
detail as you know and i had a similar
awakening or grappling as you
and in ezra's book why we're polarized
he talks about how the correlation
between the way people vote and their
policy desires are actually very low
it's only like 0.25 where right so
you're not voting on policy
what are you voting on you're voting on
tribalism and identity and
anger and
the kind of
[Music]
energy that a candidate gives off and
their attitude towards institutions and
so this is one of the things that i
grapple with in my book
and i've identified as the reason why i
need to start the forward party and make
it a success
is that there is a band of people that
did respond to me and my campaign
the policy vision
the facts
and what happened was that we activated
a certain group of people that like that
kind of thing
maybe they like me maybe they like my
you know like my particular energy and
when i started out i thought i'd be
received a certain way
i thought i'd be seen as very very lefty
because you know i was talking about
giving everyone money um but it turns
out that i have a very different vibe
maybe because i've run businesses maybe
because i seem kind of
practical
uh and so it turns out there's like a
lane
um for the practical person
um and when you talk about the things
that are animating voters uh i i now see
myself as someone who can activate a
tribe and i was joking with some people
that it's like look do i think that 51
of people love this language i speak of
facts and rationality and fixing systems
and the rest of it like probably not
um but do i think that
ten percent of americans love it and
that ten percent can do a ton of good in
a country that's polarized the way ours
is uh and the answer to that is hell
yeah you know it's like i if i get my
band of rational
uh solutions oriented
facts driven people together
and then we can come in and say look
let's fix the system so it'll actually
work for everyone and it's more
resistant to bad things and
you know more pro compromise the
incentives are more rational
i'm at heart
uh an operator type and if you arrive at
a system and you see that the system is
going to produce terrible results and oh
by the way that's what we're getting and
in this case those terrible results will
actually eventually have us at each
other's throats i'm sure i'll um
be like throwing things at
you and marshall and i'm just kidding
but uh but um you know like if you
arrive on the scene and that's the
system then the right thing to do is be
like all right let's fix the system and
then if the systems run in this case by
this duopoly you'd be like all right how
do we fix the system it's run by this
duopoly um and the answer is something
like the forward party which is going to
try and get into the guts of our system
fix the mechanics
now to do that we're going to have to
ignite a popular movement
so let's get started
[Music]
some people are into wine some people
are into chocolate and some people
listening to this right now are into
coffee and so if you can imagine getting
one of up to 400 plus craft coffees
delivered to your door with place of
origin feel like you're traveling the
world then trade is for you
and for people listening right now trade
is offering your first bag free and five
dollars off your bundle
go to
drinktrade.com yang and use promo code
yang take the quiz to start your journey
to the perfect cup
wow this sounds freaking incredible
that's drinktrade.com
yang promo code yang for your first bag
free
and five dollars off your first bundle
[Music]
you know it's funny i don't
actually believe anything i'm about to
say but i need i need to channel what a
certain part of the democratic party of
our audience feels which is you know
andrew that was a really great
articulation you gave
of why minority rule in this country is
a humongous problem
rural states are overrepresented there's
this whole divide here and we just can't
get anything done or promote fundamental
change you know what would be faster
than
passing new elect election rules and
structural changes in all 50 states
let's just abolish the filibuster let's
admit dc and puerto rico as states
let's expand the supreme court to push
back on this republican minority that's
holding back progress and change because
once again looking at the agenda of the
forward party which i'd like you to talk
about in a sec
most of it does largely line up with
what i think a center left audience is
going to be comfortable with so i just
feel as if there's a portion of the
audience you're speaking to they would
just say hey the quicker way to
guarantee we get the end of the log jam
we're talking about
is to just
change those structural things in a much
quicker way
and actually all we are doing is doing
mushy middle stuff that even if it does
work will take 48 years and to your
point earlier it's not quite clear how
long the democracy has so how do you
think and what what do you say to that
person who articulates that
well marshall i thought you're going to
go a different direction there which is
i thought you're going to say like hey
why not abolish the electoral college
which is
so
i am a practical person again and uh to
me
something like the electoral college is
just never gonna happen so you know why
bring it up now the other things that
you get talked about are more plausible
and realistic i happen to be for getting
rid of the filibuster because there's
absolutely nothing in the constitution
about a filibuster and they just made
that up at a certain point now
everyone's just kind of going along with
it it's a very odd thing in my mind for
an institution to
uh adopt um but the way our politics is
built right now is that neither side is
going to be able to achieve a sustained
governing majority by the numbers by the
math
uh and there are a number of structural
reasons for that uh you could say to
your point about urban rural and the
rest of it uh that there there's that
divide which i'd love to help reduce
uh but
republicans have a built-in electoral
advantage because there are more of them
in less populated states that are uh
overrepresented according to number of
senators electoral college et cetera et
cetera it's just the math just the way
it's set up so
if you say look let's make these things
happen by
uh
jamming it through
uh as democrats um you can look forward
to the pendulum swinging back the other
way you know x years later and and we're
going to keep playing you lose i lose
forever
[Laughter]
so that that's not a sustained fix
um though a lot of democrats imagine it
is because they just think that you know
the demographics and blah blah blah but
you know the the numbers don't bear that
out
because the population
uh
difference in states that are already
blue doesn't really make a difference
in terms of democrats electoral strength
it was a guy named david shore who said
that democrats would need to win 54 of
votes
in several elections in order to
genuinely govern and they didn't get
that against trump um so
you know to me doing some kind of stop
gap uh changes that are going to get
reversed two or four years later is the
state we're in now
no i think it's very important i think
david shore is incredibly important one
of the most insightful figures that i
think exists whenever we think
and grapple with the last couple of
years andrew
especially within your own you know
moments within the race to me
the most powerful moment of your entire
campaign
and when i saw you resonate the most is
when you were on the stage and you were
like what are we doing here we're all
wearing makeup like calling attention to
the farce of the modern political system
was incredibly powerful both to me i
mean you know i've been waiting for
somebody to say that for a long time
but i saw it kind of catch on within
the normie electorate in a way that i
hadn't seen something catch in quite a
long time and specifically amongst the
people who kind of you know are within
my audience people who are younger and
all of that how do you harness that to
political effect um obviously you know
it's not like it worked out that
particular way but you're trying to do
that this time
how are you trying to harness an
inherently
you know skeptical audience of anything
political institutions the moment you
try and formalize it from
for lack of a better verb it's a vibe
like what you projected on that stage
was the vibe of hey this is all fake
like this is all just a vacary there's
no reason that it has to be this way and
that was what the refreshing part of it
was how do we channel that into what
exactly you're talking about here how do
you think about that
no i i tried to do that in the first
section of my book which i know you
probably enjoyed for that you know i
talked about the makeup and the grooming
and the filming of commercials
and
a bunch of the other stagecraft uh and
it's really uh farcical um it's very
dark
um i'm glad that you think that that
caught on with people
uh and what i want to say is that
the entire
uh political struggle
is largely theater at this point um it's
theater that unfortunately is meant to
inflame us and turn us against each
other mainly so we can donate more money
[Laughter]
that's like the main thing
and so if we can extricate ourselves
from this and say
let me not be inflamed for a moment let
me
figure out what the real dynamics are
and what the real show is and like
what's happening to me and what they
want to have happen to me then you wind
up someplace like where i am now which
is okay
uh we're being set up
uh if i try and help from within the
system
um we're going to be in a war that no
one wins we'll all lose so let's try and
fix the system
and i hope that there's enough energy
around
uh this message so that people are
excited i love your description of a
vibe too sagar like one of the things i
have to do with the forward party is
just try and project that
infectious positive vibe and if we can
do that then i think we'll do great
because people are so sick of [ __ ] it's
like he's looking at me like oh god
what's going on what am i supposed to be
upset about now like you know i mean
there's like a lot of people it's like
true hey hey like let's
let's be sick of being sick of [ __ ]
and then let's try and fix the
underlying thing and then when someone
comes like yelling and screaming about
this and i'd be like you know what like
like
let's try and fix the incentives that
are literally driving you insane
which
and you know it's so it's a it's a
phenomenal project i am super amped
about it
uh it's something that i think is going
to
uh catch on because business as usual is
just so
uh discouraging and disgusting
can you reflect then andrew on the
hostility that you've received in elite
circles because i think what and what
marshall had previously asked you about
the electoral college republicans are
evil we have to destroy the other side
is i would say generally the prevailing
mindset either sympathetic or all-out
belief amongst the vast majority of the
cultural elite and especially in circles
that you yourself have run in have have
been outright hostile to what you're
proposing here how have you a reflected
on that hostility from people who were
very happy to have you on their program
or whatever whenever you were willing to
fit into a certain lane but b
at the end of the day we have to
recognize that those people have power
you know i've seen this in my own career
i have many more people who watch my
show than many corporate media
organizations but i have no illusions
that it's going to have the same level
of um or power whenever it comes to
influencing the political discussion so
first reflect on the hostility and be
like at the end of the day those people
do matter they control a lot how can it
be overcome
they do control a lot um but i do think
that people are starting to catch on
people are looking around and saying you
know what uh i'm not sure
that
these people are speaking to the heart
of things or the truth of things again
it's one reason why i think what you and
marshall and others are doing is so
important
um
the hostility toward me
um
suggesting something different and new
um to me is just like a knee-jerk
institutional reaction
and you would expect that
it has made me
more pumped about what i'm doing because
uh frankly and this is kind of funny
is that i think it's awesome that
it's actually newsworthy that andrew
young is starting a third party you know
what i mean it's like sure
there aren't that many people that would
provoke a negative reaction
that's very true you know
so i was like sweet like you know that
that that's dynamite uh and
i think that our
goal has to be to try and elevate enough
independent voices so that they do have
the same oomph um because
you deserve it uh
more in many cases and people are hungry
for it
uh subscribe to the realignment everyone
but it's uh but but people are people
are hungry for it
uh you know and it is interesting the
way it's playing out in our politics
where again the democrats are kind of
the last of the institutionalists um and
i consider myself like a fairly
you know positive upbeat benign figure
and whatnot and so if if someone uh
lashes out at me for some reason it's
like wow like what the hell is going on
there
you know
it's uh it it's indicative of something
i'd actually like you to speak to the
institutional question because it's a
very interesting biographical
detail given your articulation of
institutions right now because something
soccer and i always talk about is a good
way of understanding the history of the
country since watergate is just total
declining trust
and
belief and legitimacy of basically every
single institution force and figure in
american life this is the press this is
the media it's corporations it's your
local elks club everyone is implicated
no one is largely blameless that being
said you
went to an elite boarding school you
went to
brown you you went to colombia so this
isn't this isn't me trying to dunk it's
just i'm interested in how you came
about to the institutional skeptical
position
given your background because it's not
as if you are a person who's been pushed
outside of a system your entire life and
you're throwing bombs within it you're
kind of coming from the different
directions so could you just talk about
that evolution or thought process given
once again where you come from
i believe deeply in the promise of
america as a child of immigrants and so
like i always believed that we were out
to do right by people by ourselves
uh and very lucky to have gotten a great
education because my parents were all
about it
um and i think for me the big divergence
was when i left my
first job as a lawyer to start an
ill-fated.com
startup that crashed and burned and then
i worked at a series of other startups
here in new york and eventually had some
success as the head of an education
company
um and as the son of immigrants uh as
someone who is an entrepreneur and
startup guy
as one of the only asian kids in my
school district which i was reminded of
quite often
that
you know i i've always felt like a bit
of an outsider
um and
uh
you know that that's not something i you
know i'm particularly mad at i mean it's
just something that you kind of get the
vibe as you say uh and
um and at the same time like i i
actually believe in our institutions
like i believe that they
should be doing better
um i'm very disappointed when they take
criticism poorly
[Laughter]
but like i i had this naivete that
you're like hey
you could probably like fix this or do
this better that someone should be like
oh like you know thank you for pointing
that out thank you for pointing out that
this duopoly makes no sense we should
work on that um you know instead of
being like oh like you're gonna screw it
up somehow you know like i i actually
still have this sense of optimism about
what our institutions could and should
be um now they're completely floundering
and failing
on several fronts
um but
you know the arc of my family's life
super grateful this country uh you know
that they
came here to give my uh my brother and
me
a real opportunity and it's worked uh i
want my kids to have the same
opportunity and i'm gonna do my my best
uh and so i i still have that belief
um that we can do better
based upon my experiences um but you
know it's like if you go to exeter i i
mean if you look at the pictures of me
there it was like the goth kid i mean
it's not like there was like a
you know um i don't know there weren't a
ton of us put it that way
in either direction always a perpetual
outsider
[Music]
we're spending a lot more time at home
nowadays and one way to make that time
more fruitful is skillshare you can
learn design you can take a course on
self-care with jonathan van ness you can
learn how to be a more successful
youtuber or maybe become a youtuber if
you're not one already
so if this sounds like something you'd
be excited about
skillshare is for you there are so many
different classes a friend of mine is
actually the co-founder of skillshare
and it's one reason why i swear by it
explore your creativity at
skillshare.comyang
and get a one month free trial
premium membership that's one month off
a premium membership at skillshare.com
yang subscribe today and watch your
skills grow i made up that tagline what
do you think think skillshare is going
to take it
[Music]
i
am really interested in the way you
framed your skill set
in the sense that you're a builder
you're an operator
because the part of me that is more
optimistic around our ability to get
around the current political challenges
is i think that this set of challenges
is going to require and invite a new
style of leader
into the political system so it's that's
going to be someone who could deliver
nice quaffed talking points with their
thin red tie on television as if it's a
west wing episode in the 1990s it's
going to be people who can build
coalitions of people forge consensus et
cetera et cetera et cetera that's not
just padding on the back those are the
general tasks of ceos and people in that
space so i think that's an exciting note
here so i want to ask to the side of you
that does have that background
how do you think
the in the forward party
would or should be run let me ask this
specifically
are you a political reform
over everything else style perspective
or are there going to be all these other
issues because what's so fascinating
about diving into this 62 of
independence group and sauger also is
frankly like the most prominent person
building the space could really
articulate
this world that you're trying to build
in is incredibly incoherent
when you get into the deep deep deep
deal so there's the the broad agreement
about institutional brokenness
corruption et cetera et cetera but let's
just say the last thing anyone really
wants is to have iron dome funding um
thrown into the middle of all of that
um i could easily imagine a let's say
you had a big town hall and anyone who's
meant with the dsa will tell you this
too if you have a big town hall meeting
you're talking about your agenda
are you gonna say hey we're gonna put
um abortion policy to the side we're
gonna put gun control to the side we're
gonna put foreign policy and foreign aid
to the side we're just going to focus on
that issue or are you going to try to
form something coherent out of all these
different disparate bits i'm curious how
you think about that as a leader
one of the fun things about this last
week has been
all of the independent political
movements that have reached out to me
to say let's make common cause because
we're all chasing the same thing we're
all chasing
uh reform of the system that will enable
our point of view or different points of
view to actually rise up and flourish
and not get pummeled into oblivion
and
these independent groups that have
reached out to me
probably don't agree with me on
everything
but they agree that we need to
have open primaries and right choice
voting so that they have a real chance
that we all have a real chance
i'm a deeply practical person and so
i think that everyone who's sick of the
system should be getting behind these
reforms and i want the forward party to
be the leader in making these reforms
happen in real life
and
to me that should be the core issue
nothing else should matter as much
uh and that's the i think
clearing the principles of the forward
party which are and you you both have
seen this but it's uh open primaries and
ranked choice voting fact-based
governance universal basic income
because it's me
um modern and effective government
uh which i think most people could get
behind and that should be something that
pisses us all off is that we allow our
bureaucracies to be stuck in the stone
age and be like oh i guess they just
suck at things
like that that should not be
uh something we accept uh human-centered
economy which is just like we should be
the the measuring stick and then the
last one is grace intolerance which is
you disagree with me you're still an
american i love you uh you know we're
not enemies and with that as your
founding principle then if someone
disagrees with you on abortion or gun
control or
uh foreign relations you're like yeah i
guess we disagree on that it's like you
know what we can agree on the fact that
this system is broken
and i'm happy to say that a lot of
independents are on the same page at
this point like what that's one thing i
love about independence is that a lot of
them are practical
you know that last part that you got to
i think is the most important one
and i've often said that
one of the ways that you could actually
just calm things down
is to go to the extremists themselves
and just say hey
it is okay for somebody to disagree with
you i say this is somebody who comes and
has seen both sides of the world i grew
up in deep red evangelical texas where
it was also not so easy you know being
somebody of south asian descent and now
i live in the bluest city in the country
in washington dc
and to see both the polarized sets of
the movement
and to see also i mean to me and this is
the second i guess most inspiring moment
of your campaign is i remember when you
were talking about mortality rates and
you're like hey guys whether we if we're
dying you know more that's like the
basic metric like are people dying at an
earlier age something's going on
no nobody it seemed to me had ever
spoken to that in a nut a political way
that affects everyone
how
and what strategies and again i'm trying
to get to the vibe because you caught on
to this in your campaign
how
is the most effective vibe for you
in speaking to
you know the
cultural aggressors both right and left
because i think if we could just do that
just do that we could get so much
further and so much more it's it's the
one of the biggest problems we have in
politics today
i agree and one of my missions is to sit
and talk to anyone who
has an interest in having a principled
conversation regardless of whether they
violently disagree with me on things
that um you know are important to them
or important to me
uh and that has to be the starting point
really that's the vibe i want is that if
someone's accepting of people with
very different opinions which right now
is a real problem for americans like if
you disagree with them on something then
all of a sudden you're a bad person and
then you're afraid to say you know
things in various environments
that's not right most of us know that
that should not be the case
where you're living in some level of
concern or anxiety or fear that
someone's going to
attack you from being a bad person
because you hold a particular point of
view
and i'd like the forward party to embody
that energy that look
we disagree but we're all human beings
we're americans we have much more in
common um right now universality is
losing uh and it makes me very very sad
and i'd like to change that
yeah my last question here is
going over the plank of the forward
party
something will probably be noticed
as missing is no reference to money and
politics
and i'm curious how you think about the
dynamic because what's interesting is
and i should have noted this earlier
when you basically said
open primaries will encourage folks not
just to go to that 20 percent minority
in the extreme level
i think it would kind of be the opposite
because if primaries are actually more
competitive
you're gonna actually have
candidates seek to get more and more and
more money and what actually would be
effective in that strategy would be to
say hey
i actually am going to stay strong for
pro-life pro-choice gun control um gun
rights et cetera et cetera et cetera
give me money to do that i think in a
weird way rewarded you're not wrong
it really will be rewarded and i think
it actually probably pretty successful
um because you would actually be in a
weird way incentivized to lean even
further into that base because it's not
we're not australia this isn't mandatory
voting so it's not as if it's guaranteed
that the independent voters will come
out so just what's to close out the
interview what are your broad thoughts
of role and money in politics in this
whole discussion given the dynamic i
just set up
yeah there's a passage in my book about
what i think the best solution is which
is just to give everyone democracy
dollars that they can then donate to
whomever they'd like because right now
the political donor class is a very
small proportion of americans
and it does completely weed out 99 of
good candidates because they can never
raise the money um and then if they do
find themselves running then they're
going to appeal to uh
interest groups that can help fund their
campaign and that's just the market that
we've created so if i gave everyone 100
democracy bucks then all of a sudden i
get you know 10 000 people behind me
that's a million dollars and then i'm
off to the races uh like that that would
be much more balanced
um to your point about the composition
of the electorate
um i mean you would be including the
folks in the minority party in that open
primary and so you'd inevitably have
more voters and different points of view
because we're effectively
disenfranchising 83 percent of americans
right now
who
aren't going to vote in that party
primary and then by the time it gets to
the general they're like well this is a
done deal you know and anyone listening
to this i mean if you're a republican in
new york where i am or in other parts of
the country like you're an afterthought
uh you know and and the same is true if
you're a democrat in uh texas i don't
know i guess they're trying to change
that but you know
[Laughter]
wyoming
wyoming sure they're out of red state um
and that doesn't seem like a
fair system i think to most of us and so
you look at and be like wait why is it
that my vote doesn't matter it's like oh
because i'm not like a registered member
of the majority party and then there are
distortions that occur because you have
one party rule in a lot of these places
effectively there are distortions that
occur because you have a 92 reelection
rate as long as you play ball
um so uh i'm all for
trying to
balance out money in politics uh i want
to put people-powered money into
people's hands and i say that because if
i run around saying repeal citizens
united get money out of politics i mean
the fact is like that they'll have
outsized influence anyway you know what
i mean like if i make dark money a
little bit harder it's like i still
think they're gonna be all right so the
only way you can make it better is by
actually balancing it out by putting
more money into everyday americans hands
yeah
really well said andrew just want to
thank you so much for for joining us
today we really appreciate it obviously
book all of that links will be down
there in the description but you know i
just say as somebody that i has followed
you for a while and wants you to succeed
that you know i'm with you all the way
so thank you appreciate it well thank
you to both of you really grateful
sauger and
uh
it is so important what you guys are
doing um
this is a point of view that needs
to be
out there more prominently in the media
universe so anything i can do to help on
that front please let me know
what do you know man thank you so much
[Music]
you